ce pari beauvières
c'est quand même
quand est ce que mange quand est-ce
qu'on s'arrête quand est ce qu'on peut
se laver
on fera danser même nature nous regarde
un petit caprice météo dont on se
passerait bien au mois d'août puisque
après le passage pluvio-orageux de cette
nuit l'instabilité est toujours
d'actualité
non avec le soleil c'est magnifique
eh ouais
je fais partie du sel je garde les
petits enfants je rend des services à 30
à gauche adorent ya de quoi remplir les
jeunes et parfois même pas assez longue
je pratique un peu d'écouté ou la
randonnée et bien sûr les extensions
tiens chats oiseaux poissons cochons
d'inde cobayes et lapins au niveau
activité sportive la randonnée pédestre
et de la randonnée motorisée et on
parlera pas cette semaine nous nous
j'ai fait de la peinture en bâtiment la
réfection de voirie de bateaux nos
jeunes états industriels
mais il faut pas les manger mais chaque
année je fais une grande rose est tout
seul dans les vosges et pour une fois je
serai accompagné entre il sera presque
voilà des mois dans le travail j'ai une
double casquette chez l'assistante de
gestion et responsable qu est-ce qu il
ait qualité sécurité environnement
essentielle
à étaples jours aujourd'hui on fait donc
une randonnée à pied
là nous mener de la montagne ici on a
500 m d'altitude au niveau de saint
cloud globalement un peu plus ici et on
va monter lundi quasiment avec 200 m
donc quand même une étape montante on va
faire ça donc on balle en main
je suis là dans la vie hier justement du
sud et en brûle vent ou je ne sais pas
j'ai dérapé complètement et une chute pr
berger
je me suis pas fait mal donc ça va on
part c'est reparti de beaux paysages une
belle randonnée avec de belles dénivelé
très très grand nombre
oui
très agréable pas trop rapide voilà trop
lent bien c'est hyper cool mec derrière
et pas être obligé de s'en occuper
genre est devenu notre service attitré
certes il faut revoir voilà ses fils
puis pour le pro kurde et des petites
doses est doté pour ce qu'elles ont
besoin les choses comme ça donc on est
parti sur un rythme assez lent vraiment
nickel pour le coup ils vont la garder
tout le monde
ça a été donc j'ai pas envie de prouver
de gros problèmes de souffle randonnée
c'est plutôt balade et tout ça or la
main le fait de porter un chat ça casse
est lourd et puis de marcher des heures
et des heures on se rend compte que
c'est un sport parce que mine de rien
les muscles travaillent quand même quoi
c'est parce qu'il est poussiéreuse et
dole et leur présence est largement due
à l'humidité permanente qui règne sur ce
qu'ils versant de la vallée
et puis comment le disait le couvert des
pluies c'est une chose arbustes adli
auteurs
belle montée fait du bien c'est bien
chez eux aussi il reste à peu près les
110 permettre de monter encore je pense
qu'ils nous restent encore je pense que
le plus dur est à venir
nicolas affectivement qui m'inquiète
peut-être plus soucieux que que
réellement physiquement en difficulté
mais à mon avis c'est plus la question
de s'interroger si ça alors aller
jusqu'à ce soir ça peut
oui
balisé
olivier bériot non mais stéphanie
camalon qui effectivement historique des
chaussées tout ça
voilà
on va essayer de protéger surtout on
voit où ça frotte sur son sur le pied en
enlevant les chaussures j'ai regardé ma
g concert des ampoules donc guy m'a
soigné grand gentleman la gentille et
donc voilà donc c'était reparti de
nouveau pour la journée quoi
dès qu'il ya du dénivelé j'ai un peu de
mal pas très endurant on est déjà
fatigué sky et astuces qui se rajoutent
effectivement chaque fois comment ça bon
alors là on le ressent tout de suite
ben j'ai été puni j'ai été puni donc je
suis je suis de corvée de ce portage de
tentes
non c'était pour pour soulager dans le
vide
on l'attend effectivement on fait partie
de ces poids difficilement compressible
donc c'est ce qui est passé d'un halo
donc là on trouve la solution pour
terminer la journée non c'est bon
je mangeais pas de pain à vous demander
si votre voisin vous conseille de manger
on fait passer
voilà c'est bon bon ben j'ai partir de
la liste que vous avez été prises on va
faire la vérification jeu beaucoup ni au
niveau des taxes visent à faire cet
élément terre un peu une veste tu
pourras faire en auriez un ciment ouais
tu vois c'est typiquement genre de sens
qui fait partie du concours certes mais
qui est pas forcément le absolument
nécessaire des trousses de secours
j'en ai une hausse et un nom mais je
crois qu'il faut pas sont pas changé ses
habitudes parce que sinon ça risque
d'être difficile donc on va rester sur
ce qu est ce qui était vraiment pas de
trop
rien de bien détrôner n'ont rien de
court ce soir fait le point que tony dit
éventuellement possible mais bon il y
avait vraiment le strict minimum quand
il n'y avait vraiment pas d'excès
peut-être un petit peu mais bon tout
seul oui pouvait l'être
oui bon c'est pas faire passer des trucs
qui sont normalement ni combien de
femmes politiques
le portage reste reste conséquent c'est
vrai que la randonnée d'aujourd'hui et
sur des itinérances aujourd'hui on va
dire la demande ou la demande qu'on
essaie de refaire puis vous me dire on
sent que ça ça revient au goût du jour
clairement on décale sens des formules
légère de randonnée plutôt de gîtes
agite et aussi avec transport on va dire
que l'essentiel des bagages à la journée
nous transportons que que ce que nous
avons besoin pour ce venir partir le
matin et revenir le sort à l'hébergement
suivant un sac quitter on va prendre a
remporté pendant cinq heures
tout d'un coup il est bien plus
inconfortable
au début c'était lourd c'est vrai après
au milieu de la balade ça allait encore
on les sentait puis après la fin de la
valeur dont le santé mais c'est surtout
la fatigue aussi
guy m'a proposé de prendre du matériel
donc j'ai pris une tante qui doit faire
quand même même si elle est relativement
légère et de modèle à un peu moderne
doit faire dans les 2 kg 5 admettant et
puis une paire de jumelles sur cette
deuxième partie de journée on gagne
monté pratiquement 400 mètres de
dénivellation cet après-mdi cirque c'est
le second passage clé de la journée
ce qu'on a nous un premier ce matin qui
fait qu'on maintenant on est bien avancé
dans l'étape
eux se rapproche tranquillement
tranquillement d'arrivée
et on tape compagnie voilà jusqu'ici
mais qui vont bien
on va voir
bon bah
donc si tu amènes sauvage on en connaît
beaucoup plus compétitive nous et puis
quel tarif très belles fleurs celle là
et surtout quand on retourne la feuille
qui est surprenant c'est que la faille
est également très très rose est
quasiment de la même couleur que la
faire
voyez là
sommet de cette montagne et c3 tout là
haut et bas c'est là bas qu'on va alors
on l'appelle la croix des couloirs
pilote en étant radieux ce soir il est
obligatoire de passer c'est un
incontournable
ça me paraît loin mais oh oui et je me
dis qu'après on trouve pas à partir
lendemain dès samedi et audrey col
le problème c'est les vrais pompiers qui
touche sur le côté et devant donc je les
ai peut-être prise un peu un peu trop
petite une demie pointures trop petit
train
le
non
moral des troupes avancent la dernière
difficulté
donc je trouve pas possible il est
bientôt 18 heures c'est normal qu'un peu
de la sic et là je sens qu'on va y
arriver
je crois bien qu'on aurait il passé
ouais c'est ce qui m'inquiète d'ailleurs
je pense qu'on est tous un peu c'est la
journée dans les jambes comme on sait
très bien qu'il allait faire du bien
avant donc de la croix on va on va voir
cette heure d'appels et derrière on va
on n'aura qu'à redescendre en fait 200 m
des craintes et des musées et on sera
d'hébergement il sera une demi heure 40
minutes maximum
allez on y va
tout ça sent le labour fiona ouais moi
je serais prudent sa journée champignons
se voit énormément qui dit le manceau
peut cueillir poids du team paul eymond
jules et lola cars de réputation sera
pas que ce soit très beau très goûteux
forcément là on arrive à une fin de
journée on vit au jour c'est très bien
tout sept divergent d'après le terrain
nous n'est-ce pas le choix donc ça va le
faire qui deborah mais on a échangé une
chaussure tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est permet de moins de passer la
journée pour regardera ça tranquillement
on voit les bouchoux j'aime moi j'aime
bien la perspective de douche ou l'autre
si c'est bien un moment donné là vers le
bas vers le milieu ou à la fraise ou
vieux jeu souffler et puis après on
arrêtait de marcher un peu juste
on y va
donc les vacances pour autant
il y avait quelques passages un peu déjà
le la callas
donc effectivement la falaise vigilant
pour toi pour pas trébucher mais
certains passages où qui était très
étroits avec le vide un peu sur le côté
gauche
moi je suis pas trop j'ai pas trop perdu
disons que ça a été bon déjà malawi mon
but contre une pierre ou regarder ce pas
de côté
ok le vertige pour moi c'était une grand
première d'avoir franchi ce cap que
c'est un grand pays et on voit jamais le
bout et on apprécie les gens n'ont pas
tenir que le dos non plus une fatigue
ont su owni mouillé de partout ballack
c'est un sacré défi que j'ai relevé à je
me suis dit si les autres y arrive il
n'y a pas de raison que j'y arrive pas
eh ben voilà les mollets vous bien chez
lui fait régulièrement les étirements
aux arrêts justement
le soleil c'est quand cacher on l'a vu
on voit au loin bien tous les cas sur le
bas du jura on dit dans le val de saône
alors âgé présent ça ça va sûrement nous
arriver dans tous les cas cette nuit
tranquillement vers ici
donc proposé sac c'est vrai qu'il avait
un maillot sec pas loin vous pouvez dans
cinq ou dix minutes de m on commence à
voir france avait donc ça fait presque
un symbole
non non il avait mis en garde aux heures
d'ouverture là bas aussi facilement que
j'étais seul à me remonter c'est comme
si j'étais aider à droite à gauche
pour
ok 3
jetez rien je suis là je fais
paratonnerre
allez on y va
allez déborah
j'ai quand même peur en moment donné
avec ce vent qui s'est levé
les éclairs qui nous entoure est donc là
oui j'aurais pas dû courir j'aurais dû
écouter ce qu'on m'a dit abel elle que
la cour eut donc la pénombre un peu bon
avec l'orage bien entendu et puis le
terrain qui est un petit peu avec des
touffes d'herbes des des pierres donc
elle n'a pas vu un trou est la chute est
donc tout de suite on a vu que bell
s'était fait mal en quelque sorte
donc ça doit être dit et puis moi on l'a
pris sous les épaules et puis on l'a
ramené disons à l'abri mais attend de
les questionner en lisant est-ce que ça
allait aller je pense qu'elle est assez
solide mais effectivement moi j'ai
jamais jamais eu d'entorse ont donc je
peux pas je peux pas trop juger un don
qu'elle a l'air confiant pour demain
mais aussi l'âme une poche de glace mais
ça vraiment là pour le coup à coup sûr
si c'est à partir et je ne vois pas
rentrer maintenant abandonné au bout de
24 heures non pas possible
je que ça continue comme ça qu'ils
soient fiers de moi et qui voit là
montrer que je suis pas qu'une maman que
je peux être faite autour d'une petite
barre au but d'en faire une sportive
voilà et que et que tout est possible et
leur montrer que quand on veut quelque
chose et qu'on se donne les moyens on
peut réussir et que rien n'est
impossible
les ouvrages je déteste ça et sous tend
enfin nous confier à l'extérieur et
effectivement j'ai je suis parti en
courant
mais j'ai pas suivi les consignes
d'attendre le guide mais j'ai pas pu
vraiment c'était on a eu un gros coup de
pub même d'un petit peu degrés à
l'ensemble on est arrivés juste ric et
rac
on sent les prisons comme on dit chez
nous voilà combat cette fin de journée
chaotique brusquement mais bon c'est
vrai que ça arrive gentiment je vous
cache pas que depuis le village en
montant ne suis dit que peut-être assez
vite ça pouvait arriver
le gîte ici était proche et que
dominique élimine donc ils patron dit
s'ils acceptent de nous mettre à
disposition une chambre ça n'aura pas
tous un lit dormir par terre et ensuite
on a largement la tasse de dormir au sol
donc mais une pile de bach place du
doigt que c'est pour moi la seule
ça passe ok super saffon laboursois
les mines alors sa vie voit qu endurent
il est mieux que celui qui vous attend
des photos et puis la maison est
toujours ouverte à l'eau rappelle qu'on
est dans le haut jura et on a encore la
bonne idée ne pas fermer nos maisons ni
nos voitures donc le but du jeu quand
même c'est que personne ne reste au bord
du chemin
et puis les tempêtes ici sont parfois
dangereuse donc comme le mieux d'être à
l'intérieur
j'ai vécu dans la vallée de chamonix
avec dominique on avait peur des orages
dans les alpes on n'aimait pas les
orages dans les alpes ici on en a peur
c'est dans le haut jura il ya deux
saisons ya l'hiver et puis il ya le 15
août et quelquefois le 15 août il fait
mauvais il ne pouvons vous donner une
idée des températures le lieu que vous
avez choisi pour votre bivouac
il porte très mal son nom parce que ça
s'appelle chaude membres c'est l'endroit
le plus froid de la paix c'est cet hiver
il y avait moins 39 la mine de rien donc
voilà et il va parler d'un de demain
demain la météo et à terme en bourse
on est rentré dimanche mais encore des
orages annoncés dans la nuit
donc là on s'en fout un peu le petit
demain il ya un petit risque encore
dallaire ce dramatique et qui justement
là où sera créée dès la mi journée
l'installation du beau temps sexy
comores visiblement pour plusieurs jours
ça me semble bien engagé 10 ajoute cette
pièce a une bonne tisane ou claf et
peut-être les tisanes c'est bien je
viens de calais jacky à bocal avec oreca
remplit donc ça peut être qu'ils
allaient puis après benjamin libre
d'aller n'ont probablement ça se
produire mon adresse
voilà c'est très bien